Welcome friends, whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home.
It is wonderful to connect with you.
Joining us today is Aaron Ryan.
Aaron is an award-winning and best-selling
author,
speaker, panelist,
you
workshop presenter, and voice actor.
He lives in Washington with his wife and
two sons,
along with Macy the dog, Winston the cat,
and the finches Inky, Pinky, Blinky,
and Clyde. Aaron, welcome to Phoenix in
Flame.
Thank you for having me. It's good to see
you.
I actually have a very sad somber update
in that the bird count
and names have changed. So they're no
longer,
we can't do the Pac-Man, you know,
naming convention anymore because the
quantity has unfortunately gone down.
But our kids after purchasing a happy meal
from McDonald's have essentially named
them burger, nugget, and fry. So those are
the new birds.
Okay, burger nugget.
I love this. I love the kids getting that
creative space.
There won't be a quiz. Yeah.
All right. So I have so many questions,
but before we dig in, I want to kind of
just toss out a little
bit more information for the listeners and
or the viewers.
~ You are the prolific author of the
best-selling dissonance
six book alien invasion saga.
You said one of which has been adapted for
the screen and is actively being pitched
to stream on the streaming networks.
How's that going?
It's good actually, I'm really excited.
Yeah, ~ we're going a few different
routes.
So Dissonance actually was adapted by a
Hollywood fellow.
He's still not sure what exactly that
means,
but ~ it's someone who's in the Hollywood
system,
knows the producers, gets around,
actually talks with them and pitches,
writes good screenplays. He's won awards.
So he's pitching them ~ to major studios
with the producers in meetings.
And I can't say his name. can't say who
we've talked to.
It's very, you know, hush, hush,
mum. And every time I do mention his name,
then people go like, hey, pick me,
pick me for my book. And he's like,
not every book needs to be made a movie.
And then the other ones were actually
going through the film freeway
~ film festival route and they're winning
awards,
which is really flattering and exciting.
So yeah, it's a good deal.
That is fun. Yeah.
So, gosh, I could begin so many different
places,
but what comes to my mind first is for
those listeners
out there who are thinking about becoming
an author,
they're thinking about writing a book,
~ what are your words of wisdom?
What are your words of caution?
What are the things? And feel free to
share in your answer.
your journey and why in the world did you
go down this path?
There's a lot of paths you could have gone
down,
a lot of things you could have done,
Erin. And you became
Yeah.
an author.
Why this? And what words of wisdom,
words of caution do you have?
Yeah, that's a lot of questions in a Let
see if I remember everything.
You
I, gosh, I was digging through an old
photo album my mom made for my wife prior
to her becoming my wife. My wife,
that is, not my mom. And I was looking
through there and I found an
old article that she had included.
I completely forgot about it. I was in a
young author's club at 10 years old.
And there was a newspaper article done on
it from kids down in
the Stuquamie Valley and it was like,
oh my gosh, I've completely forgotten
about that.
So I was supposed to be an author.
You could call it fate, you know,
from the very beginning. ~ it's taken a
lot of different creative pursuits
and a lot of different iterations
throughout my life.
So the creativity in storytelling hasn't
necessarily always been in print
in story form. It's been in poetry.
It's been in voiceovers. It's been in
music.
And so lyrics, you know, is a form of
storytelling as well.
But I think I was always fated to be one.
~ and I think the purest, truest,
rawest form of storytelling is
writing a story. So, you know,
I love doing it. For those who want to get
started in it,
hmm, there's a lot of things I could say
and a lot of bits of advice I could say.
One, always be true to yourself.
You don't need to be the next Tolkien,
Grisham, Clancy, Collins, Lew,
Asimov, ~ Lewis. Be yourself.
You've got a unique voice and the world
doesn't need more of those people.
They're already there. I think Oscar Wilde
said,
be yourself. Everyone else has already
taken.
I
love it. ~
And
someone else said, you you're the U.S.U.
that you can be or something like that.
It was such a great quote. So be
authentic,
be true to you. Secondly, I'd say,
man, if you can steer clear of AI,
please do don't outsource your work to a
chip.
We need an original voice. Editors can't
bring out your voice if it's
not already there, you know, ~ using it
for like assistive purposes.
I don't have a problem with that,
but generative AI.
Big problem with that. is disrupting both
the the voiceover
and the authoring industry, both of which
I'm a big part of.
And third, I would tell people ~ you must
develop thick skin from the start.
You're going to face a lot of rejection.
~ You may think that your book is the
greatest thing since sliced bread,
and it may absolutely fall on its face
after you publish it.
I've got a lot of books behind me for
those joining us visually,
and not every one of those has been a
bestseller.
Not every one of those has cracked the top
100 on Amazon.
You have to run promotions. You have to
constantly market,
constantly share. There's a lot to do,
but wrap it all up, put a nice bow on it.
It's a very worthy pursuit.
I love this, I love this. So I'm gonna
make one other comment about that
and I really wanted to get more into your
personal journey.
~ I remember talking to someone one time
and I said,
sometimes I feel like a cup of water in an
ocean.
And so
Mm-hmm.
for someone in
authorship, I think most people from what
you were saying,
People want to feel like they're making a
difference.
They want to feel like what they have,
being the most you you can be and that
kind of thing.
What would you have to say? Because I know
I'm not the only one that
has that same mentality of, ~
Yes.
how to launch out, how to keep the energy
like you're describing,
because writing it, that's just the
beginning.
Because then you have the publishing,
you're editing, the publishing,
the marketing, all the things,
Erin. So
Yeah, yeah.
there's a lot of energy that needs to be
put behind that.
if someone's feeling like, what's the
point?
Let's say there's someone out there who's
super talented.
and they have a lot to share, but they
look around and see how many authors,
how many books are out there and thinking
why I feel irrelevant,
why bother, especially when they need
energy
Right, right.
to keep going. What would you say to those
listeners or viewers that
are on that path?
That sounds very much like imposter
syndrome.
Who am I? What do I matter? ~ in the light
of,
when stacked up against a ~ Tolkien or a
Tom Clancy or Michael Crichton or whoever,
who am I? And I absolutely get that.
I was wearing a shirt yesterday.
I make these custom shirts so that I can
wear them out of the grocery store.
People will go, are you an author?
And I go, well, yes, I am. then it's a
great way to,
That's awesome.
it's a conversation starter. I love it.
~
Vinyl lettering on the back of my back
window of my van so people can
see that I'm hopefully driving safely and
and will look me up ~ while also driving
safely and or make a note to look at it
later.
It's probably so many crashes always
happening behind me,
but ~ yeah, it's the imposter syndrome
thing is huge.
I don't know that I've necessarily ever
struggled with that because I've always
wanted to do it. Here's what I'd say to
those people that are,
~ you know, who am I and in light of.
There's 7,500 books published every single
day on Amazon.
Why should mine stick out? I write because
I would,
for many reasons, one of which I would
love it to be my livelihood.
I'm a voice actor who also does authoring
at this point.
I would love that script to flip someday
and be an author who also does voice
acting. And this is paying our mortgage.
Right now it's this, and that's okay.
But you don't get there in a heartbeat.
It takes a while.
But the imposter syndrome thing,
man, one of the main reasons why I write
is I love ~ seeing
it go from here, without dropping
everything,
to here. And this is my, you know,
I designed the cover, this is three books
in one,
for those joining us visually again.
This is a hardcover, I think it's eight by
10-ish.
version of my Talisman series that's all
three books in one.
And I love these types, it's a big book.
I love this, but I love more than anything
else holding this in my hand and going,
I did this. You I accomplished this.
If nothing else, I accomplished this.
As a little boy, I was in second grade,
we were all given an assignment by Mrs.
Walker. Hi Mrs. Walker. And ~ she's
probably deceased,
but I made this story called The Electric
Boy.
And it was a huge, like blatant copyright
ripoff of Alan Dean Foster's novelization
of ET. I didn't know copyright
infringement at the time.
I didn't know you could steal this and put
it here.
But I wrote a story called The Electric
Boy with construction paper
and three hole punch college lined paper
and crude stick figure drawings.
And it was just a silly little novella,
but I remember holding it in my hand at
seven and going,
I did this.
~ love it.
And going,
Oh my gosh, you know, look, and so I've
just repeated that process over
and over again with music and CDs and
books galore.
If for no other reason, do it to say,
what I did. You I did it. They could take
pride in that even if nobody ever buys it.
You want them to buy it, but you know,
you can take great pride.
Wow.
So another question that just popped in my
mind is just in response to what
you just said was, I'm really curious
about your,
what would you say to parents out there
who have children that are similar
to the little boy that you were?
Because you know, there's different kinds
of parental styles out
Thank
there. There's different personalities in
parents.
And for the parents that might
Mm-hmm.
be listening right now or watching and
they have a child who's
behaving a lot like you described how you
behaved,
what would your recommendations be for
them?
A foster it by all means foster it to the
end of yourself with every extent that
you can foster that gift I my son who is
now 10 is an incredibly crafty
kid He are tape and paper budget So I'm
taking donations and I'll give
you the Vimeo or the Venmo at the address
He is incredibly crafty every single day.
He blows my wife and I away
with what he's created, three-dimensional
stuff.
And there's nothing wrong like not to
belittle a painting or an art,
a one-dimensional art form, but these are
three-dimensional with scale and colors,
and they're really close to the original
shape that he's seen in a movie
or a book somewhere. And it's just
amazing.
And so my wife and I joke, he's gonna make
a lot of money someday,
and I want some of it. ~ You,
Yeah ~
you as parents,
you can inadvertently benefit from that
type of thing.
Not that he should be the breadwinner,
don't put that onus on him, ~ foster it by
all means.
It gives us such great delight to see him
go far.
And I think we joke also that he should
probably be employed by Stan Winston's
movie
FX studio already. He just has those
inclinations.
He has that drive. He assimilates five
minutes of a movie that we watch,
goes, it.
And then he retreats to his craft desk and
comes back with whatever he's seen.
And you know, he misses the whole movie,
but he's created something that's a
perfect physical manifestation of what
we've
all seen in those first, you know,
five, 10, whatever, 15 minutes.
Nurture that by all means. If there's
anything that you can do to,
to explore ways for that child to have an
outlet of harvesting that gift,
strengthening that gift, you can bond over
that.
And never ever, ever, ever, ever go just a
minute.
I'll look at it in a minute. I mean,
stop what you're doing. Wow, because it's
so cool.
It's just so cool.
is awesome. Now I want you to help tell us
a little bit about the genre that
you are in now. What gave you
the desire for that particular genre that
you're kind of mostly writing
in and why that and what are the pros and
cons and the feedback that you've gotten
and all kinds of stuff?
Yeah, it's a hard question to answer
because I'm very multi genre.
If you can see behind me again,
there's there's sci-fi, there's business
guides,
there's a prayer guide, there's literal
literary criticism,
there's historical fiction, there's
children's picture books,
and I kind of get a wild hair.
And, you know, I have to go down that
breadcrumb trail and see it through
to its end. I wouldn't have written
children's book books if I didn't have
kids.
I strongly believe that. So the three kids
books,
those are, you know,
a direct offshoot of having a 10 and a six
year old.
I'm currently writing my first horror
novel,
although my alien invasion saga is,
um, is horrific. Um, probably the wrong
word to attribute to it.
Um, it's phenomenal, but the aliens are,
it's, there's horror, there's Stephen King
elements of horror in there.
This is, uh, the, the current work in
progress is called blood echoes.
And it is a, uh, it is a horror novel
outright.
But I belong mostly in my wheelhouse,
which is sci-fi, post-apocalyptic,
and dystopian. I just, I love being in an
environment where hope
is the very last thing and the only thing
that you have.
Everything else has been stripped away and
it is threadbare,
the hope that you have. But I love the
quote from ~ President Snow
in Suzanne Collins' Hunger Games.
He says, hope, it is the only thing
stronger than fear.
And I resonate so much with that quote
because it's that little flickering candle
about to go out in the darkness.
And that's what you zero in on,
~ So I really belong in a sci-fi
environment where
the odds are greatly stacked against the
protagonist.
And how much do we experience that in real
life?
know, where that's, that's where we go.
with
I'm an avid reader and to me that's my
escape of choice,
right? People use different things to
escape the stress of real life.
You know, they just want to go somewhere
else for a while and not have
to think about the problems they have to
solve.
They just need an escape for goodness
sake.
Yeah.
And reading...
is mine because I can just fall into
someone else's life for a while
and just kind of just enjoy that.
it's just when you can relate to the
characters,
because I hear you describing,
you know, characters that, you know,
hope is everything's been stripped away.
And I'm kind of wondering too,
as you've been on your path, whether it's
through the voiceover act,
the acting, what you call it voiceover
acting.
Is this how?
Voice acting. Yep.
voice acting or writing?
You mentioned earlier about criticism and
pushing through and I'm kind
of wondering the hope and what are some
things that you have felt along the way?
What have you experienced along the way?
Maybe think of one example or that you had
to,
it was a criticism that you received,
it was something, a discouragement,
maybe a doubt. Wondering is this,
Is this going to happen? Is this worth
doing?
think anyone, especially entrepreneurial
Hmm.
people, because I would call myself a
serial entrepreneur and
Thank
I interact with other people that are
entrepreneurs as well.
And it's not a path for the faint of
heart.
Yeah.
So I'm kind of, and I love that
your theme of hope. So I'm kind of
wondering if you could bring together your
own experiences that might have driven
this sense of wanting to write about hope
when that's all you have.
That's a great question. think speaking
from experience and it was,
I would say it was fairly traumatic too.
~ So I'm a voice actor. was very
entrenched in the voiceover system
~ from probably about 2016 on.
I was gaining ~ some notoriety.
I was ~ winning some accolades and things
like that.
And ~ I was very inspirational.
mean, my branding is... ~
sci-fi enthusiast at heart. I'm very
enthusiastic.
I have a lot of heart in what I do.
Brought the same thing to voiceovers when
I was in voiceovers,
but I found to my chagrin that there was a
bit of an Illuminati at the top.
Those people who kind of control all the
strings.
It's them who decide, ~ you know,
who gets to speak and who gets the acclaim
and who they'll direct people
to and who is going to be kind of welcomed
into their high school clique.
And
I decided after a while, was no longer,
I always felt like an outsider,
you know, looking in. ~ I felt like I was
just beating my head against a glass wall.
I could see what I wanted, but I wasn't
going to be welcomed in.
And I found that out very painfully
through some,
you know, direct, very, honest and cutting
assessments of
my blog that I contributed. wrote 300
blogs that were meant to be very Dave,
very satirical and encouraging.
That's what all I want to do is encourage
and affirm.
higher up, Mucky Mucks said, you your
blogs basically are nothing
and they're not encouraging and you just
want to have people buy your books.
And it was like, wow, really hurt.
was just that was that is not and was not
the impetus for me writing blogs.
I took great pride in encouragement and no
one wanted to see my heart from
the the upper tiers. So it was really
frustrating.
I spoke truth to power. I was a little
unkind in my ~
my word choices, because I was very,
I was livid ~ at how I was being treated.
So I basically shot myself in the foot and
cut myself off intentionally from
the voiceover community, which had grown
very toxic online.
~ I shot myself in the foot.
I was very alone and right at that same
time is when AI was making
its foray into the market with chat,
GPT and open AI.
And so a lot of things kind of came to a
head that forced me out.
I was still doing voiceovers, know,
still working for clients, but I was on my
own now.
I was no longer doing business coaching.
I was no longer blogging because what's
the point?
And it just sapped a lot of creative fire
right out of me.
And it was a very sad time,
a very sad time.
But I have to create, that's the thing
that's just the driving impetus.
I must create or I'm gonna blow up,
I'll explode. And there's gonna be air and
goo everywhere.
Red Mist.
it's grisly,
yeah, it's grisly. Well,
yeah, it wouldn't be like a, it'd just be
like a blah,
Yes!
you know, everywhere. So,
but then I just, realized long ago I
really have to create or I will
self-destruct.
I have to do something creative.
So I thought it was music.
I ventured away from the video community
and ventured back into music
and decided after a few months,
like this is way too expensive and just
not getting the gigs.
What can I do? And I was like,
duh, I'm a storyteller. I'm a storyteller
as a voice actor.
I'm telling other people's stories.
What is more natural than, and all my
careers echo that I can walk you through.
All of them have been about telling
stories.
I just resorted back to my first love,
which was storytelling. Again,
the Young Authors Club at age 10 and the
the book I wrote at age seven.
~ I think
I have no regrets from short circuiting
that
voiceover, ~ the tedium of it,
short circuiting that process and backing
out and then following my heart
to where I really belonged. It was a
really long answer and feel free
and cut as much of that as you want.
no, I like all of that. Well, because
But.
on Phoenix in Flame, we tell real stories
and the listeners and the watchers,
Yeah.
they're like, because they're walking
this.
And that's why I always try to be very
respectful of who's listening
and who's watching and where they might be
on their journey.
Because one of the things I
Yeah.
like to talk about on my podcast is you're
not alone.
And so through the conversations that we
have,
letting other people know this.
And so I love the organic
conversation that you're having and the
transparency about the journey.
One of the things I'm wondering is through
all of that,
being exposed to the, like what you call
the Illuminati,
which we all understand what that means,
and just the criticism and the path you
were going,
it turned out, well, not today.
And so a lot of times when people are
going through that,
they have a hard time, you know,
alluding to the word that she used earlier
was hope.
they have
Mm-hmm.
a hard time holding on to hope.
And because they can't see what's coming
and they have a hard time keeping
on going when everything they thought was
going to happen is just in a pile
of ash at their feet. So for
Yeah.
you, can you look back and think of maybe
one thing that helped to keep you dry?
I know you talked about being creative.
That was something that was you did.
So I heard that. Is there anything else
that comes to mind that you would share?
with someone who might be right in the
middle of exactly what you're describing.
Well yeah, absolutely. So I'm an
entrepreneur and a freelancer.
I always have been. It's really hard for
me to work for someone else's dream.
so I, gosh,
this must have been back in 2007-ish when
I first ventured
out of full-time employment and ventured
into self-employment.
I was having all kinds of computer
problems.
Funnily enough, I'm right there again
because my brand new PC I ordered from
Origin,
I had to send it back and thankfully
they're giving me a full refund
and I'm finally going all the way to Mac.
I'm going to PC. I'll have windows in
parallels running if you understand
any of that, but I'm going to run a Mac
from now on.
~ and I'm familiar with Apple,
but anyway, it's, it's back then I was PC
entirely and I just kept having problem
after problem after problem with this PC.
I wanted self-employment so badly.
I could feel it in my teeth.
~
I couldn't, I couldn't sleep and I had all
the makings.
I had everything in place to become
uh, an entrepreneur and to pursue
multi-production is what I was trying to
do.
But this darn PC kept getting in the way.
I had already replaced the memory.
I'd already replaced the drives.
I'd already defragged. If you remember
what that
I do.
is,
I'd already done over and over all these
different things that we had replaced.
And it was like, well, why don't you just
buy a new computer?
Well, this was the top of the line
computer at the time.
My buddy said, just go buy more memory.
said, I've already swapped out the memory.
He said, just go buy more. I said,
oh, fine. I went and bought new memory.
But before that, and it solved everything,
before that though, I was so ready to give
up.
was sitting, this is gonna sound wrong.
~ Don't take it the way it sounds.
I was sitting on the toilet
Okay.
at two in the morning. I was clothed.
I was just, I was sitting and I was
bawling into a pillow.
~ I was bawling into a pillow at two in
the morning on the toilet
in my bathroom because I wanted this so
bad.
And... ~
And I remember talking to a client of mine
at the time,
graphic design, my computer crashed plenty
while doing work for him.
And he said, he shared a quote,
I think from Confucius, either that or
it's a Swedish proverb,
and it said, the temptation to quit is
always greatest just before your greatest
success. And that quote stuck with me.
A lot of mantras I have in my back pocket,
they've stuck with me.
But I remembered that because I was so
ready to throw in the towel,
even though I could feel it right here.
And I bought that memory, I installed it
in the computer,
and I've been self-employed ever since.
And that's been since 2007.
So we're going on 30, or what,
20 years now, I guess? No one said there'd
be math,
is that right? 20, 19 years? I guess it's
19 years.
You're mouthing out loud.
Yeah,
it's almost.
It's almost 20 years, almost two decades
of self-employment because
of two memory sticks. And it has paid our
mortgage.
It has bought us several cars outright.
It has funded my authoring dream.
It has enabled us to give freely to others
without asking for this,
this financial gift back. It's enabled me
to pursue wonderful hobbies
of like having a custom Lord of the Rings
book that is a keepsake that
is red leather bound.
It is silver foil stamped. I love this
book.
I had this made. I put pictures of the
movies where they're appropriate
to the running narrative. I had this whole
thing made and it cost
a fortune because I had three.
The self-employment paid for that.
So I am incredibly grateful for the that
Phoenix moment and the Phoenix moment
of leaving the voiceover industry because
there were flames,
but you have to endure those, I guess.
What you're describing reminds me of a
conference I attended recently
and the speaker was talking about going
from breakdown to breakthrough
and then wash, rinse, repeat, breakdown
No, that's good.
to breakthrough, then breakdown to
breakthrough.
It's not a one and done. It's a cycle like
wash,
Wow.
rinse, repeat, breakdown into
breakthrough,
breakdown into breakthrough.
I thought, wow, and for anyone who's been,
who's lived long enough on this planet and
especially entrepreneurs know exactly
what that feels like. ~
Right.
It's just, going through that is just kind
of,
the woman who said that is Dr.
Brittany Iselle, ~ E-Z-E-L-L. She was a
former coach
for an ETSU women's basketball team.
I want to make sure I give her credit.
for saying that. She was giving
Yeah.
a talk on, know, kind of athletically
being resilient and being a leader
and looking at it from an athletic
standpoint and how it's similar,
you know, trying to be a leader and try
how it's similar to being an athlete.
And she was the one that said that.
Thank you, Dr. Oselle. ~ Break down
I love it. Yeah.
into breakthrough and then break down into
breakthrough.
And that's what I hear you saying.
just typed it so if you saw me you know
doing this I have to save that that's
a wonderful quote. Wow.
Yeah, that's Dr. Brittany Iselle and I'll
try to remember and tag her
~ when this podcast comes out.
Yeah.
She's fabulous and
I'm wanting to get to talk to her more.
So in the last few minutes that we have,
I'm kind of wondering, you know,
this is going to be really hard question
and I'm going to ask it anyway.
Do you have a favorite book that you've
written?
Do you have a favorite child in your
in your book groups. What would it what's
your favorite
Yeah.
one? Do you have one?
Yeah, I do. mean, I'm working on book
number 45 right now,
so there's a lot to choose from.
But it used to be a tie. So I really love
my The End series.
It's a Christian dystopian saga,
and the finale in it is called The End
Omega,
and it is powerful. It's loaded with so
much redemption and heart,
and you're gonna cry. don't care who you
are,
you're gonna cry. There are powerful
moments of reunification in there and
triumph.
with a capital truh. I mean, it is so rich
with heart,
that book. However, as much as I love the
end omega,
I wrote a historical fiction novel called
Forecast.
It is a 9-11 historical fiction novel.
I still to this day remain deeply moved,
deeply moved by the heroism of the fallen
heroes and victims of 9-11,
the 343 firefighters, know, the passengers
on flight 93.
And not a lot of people want to deal with
that subject still two decades later,
or almost 25 years later, it's sad.
I looked at that project as a catharsis
for me.
I really wanted to write something that
would undo 9-11 and save
all those lives vicariously in a fictional
setting.
So that's what happens. 9-11 is utterly
prevented.
I mean, that's the spoiler, but you know
it's coming.
But in that book,
I actually there's so many Easter eggs
I've lost count and in that book
it goes it's written first person but it
migrates
to third person because he has to split
personalities at the end and then
it joins back to first person
~
and so it was such a challenge to write
that book but it turned out so good it's
so compelling and wouldn't we all love to
live in a world where 9-11
was prevented. So that's probably still at
the top.
And I also really love the Phoenix
experiment.
It's the first book where I really
incorporated a lot of prose.
It's the first book where I wrote first
person present tense.
~ So yeah, each one is is new.
Each one is exciting and different,
but those are the top ones.
That's
fabulous. Well, and I have to ask a
question because I reached out to,
I have a cousin, Jill, shout out.
She's an
I don't.
avid reader and she works at a library and
she has her degree in library science
and all this. And she also, she had a
question about
the Christian dystopian genre.
she was recalling and referencing the Left
Behind series and she was
Yes. Yep.
saying that, you know, the feedback that
she had received was that there
was quite a few people that were like
traumatized by that,
by, you know, I guess the concept of being
left behind.
You know, if you were like a younger
Yeah.
person or like, what the fuck,
right? So, and so I...
you
told her I told her I'd ask and so I'm out
there and I'm asking you know what what
are your thoughts on
Yeah.
that you know that kind of feedback on the
Left Behind series and then
how do you how did you overlay that with
the book the books that you wrote?
Yeah, it's a perfectly valid question.
I ~ was very inspired by the Left Behind
series.
I didn't actually complete it.
I think I read through book nine or
something like that way back in the
90s and got distracted and I was like,
yeah, I should get back to that someday.
~ There's a few profound differences
between that series and mine.
So the ~ Left Behind series is really all
about revelation and the seven year period
called the tribulation according to the
Bible.
before Jesus returns and the Antichrist
rises and the false prophet
and you've got the know, the mark of the
beast and blah blah blah.
I was inspired by it, but that doesn't
mean that the end is a carbon copy
of Left Behind. The end is more a ~
dystopian setting.
The antagonist is a man who literally
believes he is the Antichrist of
Revelation.
He's not. This isn't the tribulation
period.
It's not the period right before Jesus
returns.
~
It is very dystopic in that he is a
madman.
mean, how many times in history have we
seen people that have power
and are just absolutely bonkers and they
are,
I'm not making a political referendum
here.
I promise I'm not, but they're dangerous.
That is such a danger when you have
someone at the top with that,
know, megalomaniac complex and they're a
totalitarian despot.
I love this story because it is entirely
feasible.
I'm not gonna say probable, but it's
This man, in my series,
~ because of who he believes he is,
he is hell-bent on a second, ~ gosh,
I'm now phasing out on the word,
~ when they killed off the Jews,
~ Holocaust.
Holocaust.
He's focused on a second Holocaust and
it's the extermination of Christians
in the year 2113. Under the guise of a
census,
he has them all secretly branded by laser
scan.
He's got an army of mechanoid robots
called guardians.
They're really only guarding him and they
are trained to hunt for one thing.
And so they're gonna hunt down Christians.
This is impossible to extinguish this
mark.
So it's about again, clinging to hope that
threadbare hope running
and existing entirely in the shadows.
taking down someone who, whether or not
you agree with the Christian side
or the exterminating Christian side isn't
the issue,
it's the issue of what is humane,
what is morally right and who is morally
bankrupt here.
You can't just go around killing everyone
that you don't like.
And so the stakes are super high in that
series and it just goes like this.
It's an exponential curve to the very end
~ of the end omega.
So tell your sister, absolutely get it.
If she liked Left Behind, get this one.
It's not quite the same in that it's not
Revelation,
it's not the Tribulation, and he's not the
big A antichrist.
He's a little A antichrist. But lowercase
a,
~ my god.
but it's good. Yeah, I'm so proud of it.
~ it sounds fabulous, Erin.
So I know that my listeners and the
viewers are thinking,
~ my gosh, how do I get access?
How do I learn more about Erin Ryan?
So the website that I have, let me verify
with you to make sure it's accurate,
is authorerinryongroup.com.
Well, authorerronryan.com is the main
domain
Okay.
and that goes to my site with all the
things and all the social links.
But yeah, they can go to, that's a sub,
that's a forwarding site.
Authorerronryangroup.com is only a
forwarding
URL that will take you to a private and
exclusive Facebook group ~ where
you can find out about the status of the
screenplays.
You can get discount codes and giveaways
and upcoming appearances and news.
But the main site that has the links to
the other sites and all
the socials is author Aaron Ryan com
Fabulous. Erin, I really appreciate you
spending your valuable time
and your energy and your wisdom and your
experiences with me and all
of us on Phoenix in Flame. Thank you so
much.
Thank you so much for having me,
I really appreciate it.
All right, listeners, viewers,
I know you have heard multiple things
today that you're thinking,
have a best friend, I have a family
member,
I have a coworker that needs to hear what
Aaron Ryan said.
Take this podcast episode, copy and paste
it,
send it in text, send it an email,
post it on your favorite social media
sites so we can grow our Phoenix
and Flame community and let people know
you are not alone.
I hope your day
Yeah.
is going great. I hope the rest of your
day is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix in Flame.